foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
office co-host of the smart money happy
hour and my daughter is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jonathan is with us in Morganton West
Virginia hi Jonathan how are you
hello Dave better than I deserve how are
you just the same sir how can we help
awesome I've known your voice uh for
probably 20 years now I'm 31. my father
listened to you as I was a child I
strayed from the path a little bit
leaving college but we're back on it now
we paid off about 110 000 in debt in
three years we're on baby step six uh
wife and I got married in 2017 we are
now expecting our fourth child in uh in
February our oldest is four turning five
next month and uh that's a lot of kids
a lot of kids under five
I know I'm the oldest of 11 so the more
the merrier uh God will provide
amen but our our house is 1200 square
feet uh we bought you know what we could
afford back in 27.
um Valerie has gone from about 90 to
160-ish uh since then but my wife really
wants more space for the fourth kid our
house is only 1200 square feet and we're
wondering if we should just you know be
content uh pay off our house and go from
there or if we should look at buying a
bigger house or look at remodeling
options uh we really like the location
we're at in our property we've got five
acres out in the country the kids love
it
um but my wife has really been looking
and wanting more space and I'm wondering
if I'm being a cheapskate
um and and wanting to be content with
what we have until we get it paid off
so in your mind Jonathan once you pay it
off would you be open to moving then
I I suppose I suppose I would be or what
you're saving that money to do a remodel
and get more space what's your household
income
awesome my wife is a stay-at-home
homeschooling mother of our kids and uh
I have a mining engineering degree I
work for a coal mine as a supervisor uh
my salary is 120 after bonuses last year
our gross was 160. okay and our net
worth is uh net worth is 450 right now
all we owe is uh 150 on the house and
it's probably worth 200 or 220 somewhere
okay uh I've done a lot of um
remodels in my real estate life and um
I would strongly recommend with that
many children under the age of five that
you not try to do a remodel
um there would be a murder
it's just one of my wife's concerns yeah
well I think you I think you like the
acreage and I don't really blame you for
that
um that many kids in 1200 square feet is
pretty tight I don't think it's an
unreasonable weird thing to say you know
like we're not being out of control
opulent or something like that to try to
move up a little in-house you know get a
little bit more square footage since
you're going to have uh this many
chickens in the coop and so
um yeah I but I I you know it might it
might take a little time to find a piece
of property that or a house that's a
little larger on a piece of property
because you like the acreage and again I
don't blame you for that I like a little
space myself I can't stand these things
they're crammed in on top of me but uh
um but anyway
yeah that that so I I you do make enough
money to sell that house and to move up
into more square footage you just got to
be careful about how you do it so that
you don't take on too much house and
that the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay yeah and I
think Jonathan sitting down with your
wife and you guys you know talking out
like hey what do we want
the next five to ten years to be like in
our home what do we want it to feel like
do we want the freedom of do we value
more acreage because I know when you're
you know when you have kids like that
yeah you're growing up and they're able
to run and do stuff or do we value a
neighborhood where there's other kids
and we can all play like you you guys
have to really figure out your values
and what you guys want your home to feel
like and be as a family and then your
house can reflect that and so it may
take some time to find something that
meets both of those but that's what I
would try to kind of figure out and
you know and maybe in a season that you
kind of give up some acreage to get some
home you know a bigger home just to get
through you know the kid years and then
once they hit Middle School you know you
can even move up again or or change
locations so a house isn't forever I
mean it's it's us obviously a major
purchase and a big life move
um so you want to be wise about it but
um but yeah I think you guys can can
definitely afford something more yeah
the thing you want to guard against
folks is and Jonathan's trying to do
this by asking the question is this idea
that you just always move up and always
have a mortgage
oh I'm going to always have a mortgage
so I might as well move up and I'll just
move up and I move up and I move up and
it it kind of falls in the same bucket
of oh I got a 232 a month raise at the
office so I'm gonna go take out a 300
car payment right you know I'm not that
that's not what we want to do we want to
go the other way so um but you know I
don't think that um
you know you you didn't call me up and
say she has a 4 000 square foot house
and she wants a six thousand square foot
house sure you know you call me she's
got a whole bunch of humans in 1200 feet
there and she's homeschooling yeah so
there's room for I mean like that yeah
yeah it's very Justified and so you
could look at adding on to that current
property but I would advise against
doing a rehab while you live in a house
with a bunch of small children I just I
think it's a nice stressful yeah I mean
we've done minor Renovations and I
didn't like that it was no fun so
building a house is one thing where
you're not living in it uh that's a
different project that's a whole
different thing it's all the mess is
over there somewhere but if every night
when you sit down to eat dinner there's
sawdust on your plate that starts to be
old fast and um it doesn't and it just
seems to drag out forever so I would not
recommend that just as a lifestyle
decision more than the issue of uh might
also overbuild the neighborhood you
might over build the price range all
that kind of stuff but which is what a
lot of people do when they add on but
you know that's what you these are the
things you got to consider but it's a
contentment is a big deal and we often
say Rachel and I and every all the
Ramsey personalities that it's one of
the most powerful
of the financial principles if you can
learn to be content you can get out of
debt if you can learn to be content
you'll always have margin in your budget
if you can learn to be content you've
got money to give and be generous with
got a margin you can learn to put you
have money to put in an investment yes
yeah yeah and
and on the other end of that
a level of space with these kids
what she's presenting isn't in my
opinion discontentment it's more just a
quality of life crazy moments yes
in a small cage I mean it's just oh my
gosh you know it's
I keep all the grandkids and and we got
a big house and it's not big enough so
they find ways to drive you all crazy I
love them fantastic they're awesome this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
Cruz Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money hey those of
you that tuned in last night for the
student loan free live stream uh there
were I guess it looks like right now
we've probably had over a hundred
thousand people already view it thank
you for that we really appreciate you
guys turning out and uh Rachel and Jay
did a stellar job and
um I bookended it so there we go hey we
appreciate you guys hanging out with us
hopefully it helps those of you that was
really tuned in that's what we content
the way you guys did what y'all did
covering the budgeting stuff was really
good well yeah I we well we wanted
tactical stuff and I feel like that's
one thing that's so hard especially with
these payments coming in October for a
lot of people they're looking at their
money and they're like I mean I don't I
don't know I don't even have margin
right now so
um hopefully us kind of walking through
and showing you examples of what it
looks like to cut what it looks like on
the income side to you know even looking
at pausing investing how much money that
can bring back into each paycheck so
yeah we got really detailed in it but I
think
um I mean you took the every dollar
Apple I'm actually built budget live on
the thing it was pretty cool yeah so and
actually the link I think is up still at
ramseysolutions.com student loans or on
um oh you can watch it on YouTube okay
I'll make sure yeah to check it out
because we put out put it out last night
hoping that uh it gets you guys
Direction and also we're heading to
Chicago uh momentarily and we'll be up
there to do smart conference Friday
night and all day Saturday if you're in
the Chicagoland area don't have your
tickets get them get them but the
morning session the first couple of
hours on the couple of Money Talks will
be Jade and George and they will be live
stream for free
uh you don't have to pay a thing you can
just watch the uh the startup of
Saturday morning smart conference and so
make sure you check all this out go to
ramsesolutions.com events and again
that's Friday evening and Saturday if
you're in Chicago uh if you're not and
want to catch the live stream in that
Saturday morning it will be live and it
will be Jade and George and a little bit
from you a little bit right uh no no no
no not in the afternoon okay maybe a
little bit for me
I'm doing a little intro thing too so
yeah all right you'll see us Jason is in
Shreveport hi Jason how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up
okay so I'm 40 years old I am a
classically trained opera singer and
music teacher when I was 27 I was
working on my PhD I had a grand mal
seizure that year the next year I had
another grand mal seizure I was
diagnosed with epilepsy fast forward to
2020 I've had my second brain surgery
three weeks before we went into lockdown
wow they removed they removed 10 of my
brain
um I'm on the mend in terms of the
epilepsy but
there is no cure for epilepsy it's never
going away what is not going away is my
student loan debt
so when I go to try and buy a house they
factor in one percent of that total
amount as a monthly payment that I'm not
making because I'm on an income driven
repayment plan
and I have tried to file for the total
disability discharge and was denied why
apparently well because they said that
my my uh epilepsy wasn't severe enough
however when I went through the
disability process it was a retired
gynecologist making the decision as to
whether or not I would be so you're not
on SSI you're not on Social Security
I am now finally it took permanent
disability
no well it's not permanent I I have to
re-re-qualify every three to five years
I'm waiting on that next uh set of
paperwork well the retired gynecologist
didn't do that that didn't get you into
SSI
well
you had to have another there had to be
another medical professional
professional on that part of the story
right
well I have a I have a neurologist uh
like a epileptologist and uh and they
gave you the paperwork for the for the
Social Security Administration to
approve the SSI disability
that's correct okay and your your your
uh Denial on the student loan idiots was
before you got this SSI approved
no no
they said my condition was not severe
enough
okay listen the answer to the equation
is I'm not stopping on that dude you're
disabled fair enough okay okay yeah the
answer is I'm gonna go Congressman
Senator uh uh I'm gonna hire an attorney
uh you got 300 000 wrapped around your
neck that's not going away that should
be forgiven is that how much debt it is
Jason yeah that's how much I have in my
name my wife my wife so I have 297
000 in student loan debts starting in
um my wife also has an additional two
um he has her doctorate that's correct
what does she do for a living I'm fine
she's now a college professor making
what
um she's a tenure track Professor making
fifty one thousand dollars she just got
this job this year we just moved a month
ago
it's a really good job for her
now I was hoping to have the same kind
of position but without my exit degrees
help me with this because I'm sorry I'm
struggling with 51 000 and we call that
a good job
so tell me how this works she's on a
tenure track does that mean she's gonna
be making 120 in three or four years
we don't know the final number but once
she's granted tenure and seven years the
income does go up drastically yeah and
it should go up incrementally between
now and then also
I'm hopeful that that will be 1 000 of a
PhD teaching at the University level
sounds low period whether there's tenure
or not
I agree okay I agree it's uh it's a
tough world out there uh no it's not
that I mean I'm telling you it's not
that's not right that's too low other
phds are teaching at the college level
make a lot more than that that's what
I'm saying so I don't know whether this
is the particular University she got on
with uh or maybe it's the degree of
field I don't know uh but
um so the answer to her 200k is for you
guys to get your income up and get rid
of it the answer to your 300K is could
God is uh half a million dollars is uh
for you to go after these guys on the
disability issue because I mean you've
if one the trick with a disability with
them is to get if the Social Security
Administration has declared you're
disabled and put you on SSI that should
be the ticket
and I should just straight up forgive it
now is there a difference with it not
being permanent the fact that he has to
reapply every three to five years
you have to re-look it all the time
anyway they're you know if you become
undisabled you're not you know you you
lose that but yeah that
I I'm telling you man I am spending some
energy and some time with uh Senators
Congressman staff uh and an attorney and
I'm gonna get this gone if I'm in your
shoes I think I think that should be
forgiven that's what it's for I mean
upon death or disability federally
insured student loans but disability
isn't I feel bad disability is the
Social Security Administration has
declared you disabled and that's that's
the debt that's the definition for
purposes of student loan forgiveness and
that's a standard program that is not a
Joe Biden helped you out that's that's
been from day one that program has been
there yeah wow Jason I'm so sorry you
guys are facing this what a horrible
process y'all have been through
and the student loans have just made it
worse
so um man that's awful
um and at risk of sounding like I'm
piling on him because I'm not
um but that should that kind of a phone
call for this show should be a warning
to some of you
that you don't go two hundred thousand
dollars in debt to get your PhD to make
50 Grand
okay those numbers don't work and you
don't go three hundred thousand dollars
in debt to Live Your Dream in the uh
Opera world because you could end up
with a medical condition and end up in a
mess and it probably isn't even that
lucrative of a well I mean it is if it
is it's it's uh you know but it's it's
like anything else in the music business
it's there's a percentage that make all
the money and a percentage that wish
they did and um so but either way the
you cannot bet 500 000 on these tracks
that's not this is what gets you in
trouble and because then life happens
and you end up here and I'm gosh Jason
I'm so sorry you're there I'm not
picking on you but the rest of you
should take a warning from this and if
you got a kid wanting to go on this
track tell them no no we're not doing
this no
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
retro Cruz Ramsey personalities my
co-host today thank you for joining us
Brian is in Portland Oregon hey Brian
how are you
I'm well Dave thanks so much for having
me uh on
um
so I'll get right to the point um it's a
bit of a first world-ish uh problem but
I'm not sure step seven point and I
guess my my biggest concern is balancing
obviously how much I really should spend
now based on the amount we have based on
or the comparing it towards how much do
we need to save because I mean we're at
a point where our total retirement plus
non-retirement assets are over a million
we're incredibly fortunate and in some
cases unfortunate because of why we got
to that point but uh at the same point
we're really trying to balance out
exactly
yeah it's easy to say let's just live
off the returns and with the two of us
combined make about 165 170.
um
I'm 42. okay all right good good for you
guys well done millionaire huh and so I
take it you inherited some of it the way
you said the way we got it I guess some
you lost someone
yeah uh there's um we we lost some
family at a very young age uh relatively
to where they should have been I'm sure
that way I'm sorry thank you well uh but
some of the work was obviously on our
own as well we didn't start and just go
from zero to hat to a million without
doing any work ourselves we're
definitely proud that we were at least a
chunk of the way they're on our own yeah
okay
um well I mean Rachel can speak to this
she does a lot of work on contentment
the
two things that Sharon and I do is
um one where we had to learn to look at
ratios
because your emotions can't keep up with
your wealth building
I mean look at you look up in a few
years you have five million dollars you
don't feel like you have five million
dollars you feel like when you had fifty
thousand your emotions don't keep up
okay and so to to circumvent that we had
to say all right we can afford a ten
thousand dollar Cruise
how do we know we can afford that and we
use the burn it in the middle of the
floor test if I took that much money and
I made a little fire in the middle of
the floor and I burned ten thousand
dollars would my life change
no
yours wouldn't either by the way
okay
so so I can go on that or Sharon can go
on that cruise and I get to go with her
so um uh so you know we can make that
decision then because basically we're
burning that money right it's gone poof
we enjoyed it we experienced it it's a
good thing I mean it's why we work you
work we live like no one else so that
you can live like no one else so that's
ratio I look at ratios and so if we're
going to buy a car for 50 000 or 60 000
or whatever a hundred thousand whatever
it is if I drive the car off a cliff
with no insurance does my life change
no
then I can afford the car
it's a non-issue mathematically does
that make sense
and so that helps me to spend money that
my emotions don't feel like I should do
like because your emotions say things to
you like you used to say to other people
like no one needs a car that nice nobody
ought to drive something like that this
is what people say right that's where I
came from this is that neighborhood
right it's you know who needs to you
know but I had a guy making 15 million
bucks since a friend of mine pull up in
a dad blame whatever uh Ferrari or
whatever the flip it was 400 000 bucks
okay but he made 15 million last year
so him drink getting a 400 000 car
is like okay if you made a hundred and
fifty thousand you bought a four
thousand dollar car it's the same ratio
it's some non-issue but it's just hard
to get your head around a four hundred
thousand dollar car I can't I can't
grasp it but it helps me grasp it if I
look at ratios that's what I'm always
doing what's the ratio on this and can I
burn it in the middle of the floor the
second thing that has helped me is uh we
uh make sure at all times we are doing
three things and Rachel and I taught
parents to do this with their kids at
all times you should always be
increasing your generosity as your
income goes up you should be increasing
your Investments as your income goes up
and you should be increasing your
enjoyment
your lifestyle spending as your income
goes up and we at Sharon and I use a
percentage on that every time I get a
big check from the publisher for a Total
Money Makeover I get big old checks on
that because that thing still sells like
crazy and when I get that big old check
in I've got an automatic percentage 40
for taxes 10 per tithe so there's 50
gone okay then I've got another 50
percent how am I going to allocate that
I'm going to allocate it among those
three things a percentage that we have
set in our formula you make up your
formula we made up ours but a percentage
of that 50 towards lifestyle a
percentage towards investing and a
percentage towards increased generosity
beyond the tithe
and so we're always giving more we're
always enjoying more and we're always
investing more and that keeps me in
Balance too yeah yeah I mean that's
that's well said and I think too Brian
what's helped
I would say my husband and I over time
is I'm like we've learned to live so
significantly below our means just
because it's almost like this litmus
test of like we're fine we don't we
don't need to continue just to consume
and consume and consume even if the
money's there so we do though look at
percent what he's saying about
percentages and we've upped we up our
percentage a few percentage points it's
not a ton honestly
um you know maybe per year every two
years as we're doing our budget month to
month and we look to say okay because we
want to be able to enjoy it because I
hear what you're saying you're like if
we're working hard and we have the
ability to enjoy some of it we want to
and so for me I find more enjoyments
personally in more of the day-to-day
stuff when I can like up the grocery
budget a little bit and go to Costco and
buy a few more things or go bike more
clothes or like whatever it is like
these like very small percentages in our
budget month to month that's where I
seem to enjoy you know that baby step
seven life but it's a but it's a very
small percentage
because over time too you're going to
learn like stuff is just stuff and
there's not like you know spending an
outrageous amount of money not that it's
right or wrong but there's a point that
it's like
it doesn't get you what you think it
will over time enough Lobster it tastes
like so yeah so I mean like there's that
but then the big purchases is another
thing Brian I would say is for you and
your wife to still have a goal always be
saving for something and once tonight it
was our house we moved in in 19 November
2019. and we went probably like I'd say
probably six seven months without
anything that we were working towards
after that because we were so tired it
had been years and years and years of
that goal and honestly it was funny
because we got to this point like six
months after we moved in
and I was like I feel sloppy with our
money a little bit like because we're
not working towards something and so now
it was a pool and we're just now
starting that conversation for you know
four years three and a half years in the
making but always have a thing that
you're kind of looking towards because
it just keeps you with those guard rails
um especially on baby step seven that's
what that's what I found so upping your
percentage of Lifestyle month you know
throughout the month in your monthly
budget per year a little bit I think
it's great to enjoy some of it you have
to build the emotional muscles yes by
intentionally doing all three things
with some kind of a system uh and
because the people that we see that get
in trouble are someone that does only
one of those in abandons the other two
they're so generous they give everything
away and they kill the ghostly and the
golden egg or they put they put
everything in investing and they have no
life and their wife leaves
you know or yeah because they're cheap
you know because they're Cheapskate you
know or we spend it all and we put
nothing in investing and nothing for
generosity well that's most people and
that that you know that that's not one
you have to train people to do usually
but it is normal when you have been very
disciplined
to have trouble letting go of money for
enjoyment that is a normal human
reaction and it has helped me that I'm
increasing my generosity that kind of
gives me emotional permission to enjoy
some of it on the other hand
and it's helped me to do the burn in the
middle of the floor amount it's a small
so your budget still Brian I Winston I
every month we and we still track our
transactions every dollar like keep a
pulse on it because that also allows you
to see okay we have X amount and out to
eat we're gonna go on a really nice date
night right if we have some money there
so that budget also gives you that
permission to say we're okay we're not
going crazy you know nothing's out of
control here this is what we've allotted
so I would still encourage the budget
even on baby step seven because
day-to-day decisions it allows you to
give yourself permission to spend and it
works Brian I've even gotten Rachel's
mother to where she can actually spend
money now if she's the world's biggest
tight wad this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsay
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for hanging out with us America
we're glad you're here I'm Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz is my co-host today
Courtney's in faustin hi Courtney
welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
I just wanted to get your opinion on
something I am currently living in my
grandmother's home and I may potentially
soon have the opportunity to purchase it
but at the moment I have I've been
working on the baby steps I'm fairly new
I've paid off credit card I've paid off
my car and I have my student loan debt
it's about just under 33 000 and I do
have savings that I've been working on
for a down payment on a house in general
before I knew it was a possibility I
could purchase the home I'm living in
now and I have about 56
000 in there I was going to just pay off
my student loans good but people very
close to me on people I trusted they've
been telling me it's not a good idea I'm
sure the people you trust are sweet but
they're broke and it is a good idea you
should pay it off now
immediately today say next week the
opportunity comes for me to purchase the
house I'm in you shouldn't buy a home
while you have student loan debt
okay
and the home that Courtney is it your is
it your grandmother's home that you're
talking about purchasing
yeah so so there's no is there a major
timeline rush in that
but yeah it's uh it's a confusing
situation I suppose no
um but she may need nursing home care
soon and she actually transferred the
home about three years ago to my father
and his sister my Aunt and so if she
needs a nursing home in the next couple
of years the home would still be in the
uh the Medicaid five-year look back
period so they would have to transfer it
back to her it would have to be sold for
fair market value those things so I
can't buy the house yet unless uh her
condition keeps worsening and she needs
to go to the go to a nursing facility
which why is she going to Medicaid
nursing why is she going on welfare
I I'm not that I'm not sure is she broke
she has
she does not other than her home if she
were to transfer back and um I wear
Tobias from her she doesn't have much
assets or income is my understanding
um
you're you're not gonna like this but
I'm gonna tell you anyway okay
sure you're buying this home at fair
market value and it's not a home you
would have bought you're only doing it
because of the situation and it got
thrust right in front of you if you were
just walking around living in a
one-bedroom apartment you would have not
bought this house
and if you're paying fair market value
there's zero reason for you to buy it
and what I just said is true isn't it
I I no I don't I disagree because it is
in the area I'm looking to purchase in
it has two bedrooms and it's what I'm
looking for so I think that I would
purchase it okay
and what will be the value
it's a it's valued at about 450 000. and
what do you make
I make about a hundred and twenty
thousand a year
well so I the the thing that we teach
folks is the shortest right way to
wealth and that would be have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and be debt free plus your down
payment before you purchase a home and
then if you're purchasing a home that
way you would take out no more than a
15-year fixed rate loan where the
payment is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay I'm not positive that
formula fits in your situation it might
but that's a lot of house you're single
and how old
I'm 28. okay
ah
I mean you you certainly can do all of
this but I would never do it unless it
met those guidelines that I was talking
about and you do not have a down payment
plus an emergency fund plus being debt
free because you'll have 23 000 left
corn after you have your student loans
so I would kind of figure out okay what
would an emergency fund be for you and
yeah I mean I would say since if you
have a stable job you're single no kids
you know you're in that situation I
would lean more on the three-month side
and save up three months of an emergency
fund we got 55 now minus 30 is 25 so you
probably got your emergency fund yes you
don't have an emergency fund debt free
and a down payment down payment so if
it's the house you want Courtney I mean
you're not going to buy it well not
today but I'm saying if she's if her
health doesn't decline and she doesn't
have to move if you've got two years to
save up a down payment that's right yeah
that's right that's right but right now
we wouldn't encourage you regardless of
the situation of family or not
yeah you're not in a position really to
to buy that so and there are some
guidelines on the Medicaid and look back
on the five-year look back I and the
fair market value there's a also a
certain number of dollars that um she is
allowed to keep out of her principal
residence it used to be 78 000 I don't
know what it is now but so you guys need
to get some um you sound like you've
gotten some information you may I mean
you might have gotten it from the law
firm of Google and Google but you might
want to talk to an actual elder law
attorney and actually find out what you
can do because my guess is fair market
value I'd want to know what the
definition of that is in this situation
because is it because that she
transferred the house right you can't
move assets out of your name in order to
look like you're broke to qualify for
welfare Medicaid is welfare and if you
go to a Medicaid nursing home it's for
broke people that have no money and you
can't be sitting on a four hundred
thousand dollar house and act like
you're poor okay so that that's the
principle so and if you transfer it to
your kid which is what granny did she
moved it to her son and daughter in
order to hide it they have a five-year
look back and if they prove you did it
with intent to hide it it's called fraud
so it's a big problem I know because in
an Ideal World what you she if if you do
if you are in the situation and you have
a parent that is needs help then then
you sell the house and take care of them
take the 450 000 and go into great
nursing home because in with rare
exceptions there's a difference in a
Medicaid nursing home and a regular
nursing home right there's a difference
in government provided housing
people listening out there if they find
themselves in that situation the the the
right best thing to do for the parents
is take care of them it is to sell the
house and take care of them and use that
money to go into
not about Medicaid look back and how we
can hide our Granny's assets so that we
can put her on welfare and we're not
saying Courtney that that's what you
guys did no but that's why the Medicaid
look back is there that's my five-year
look back is to keep people from
fraudulently hiding assets and uh and
they can if they find it they can undo
it and what she's saying is her family's
going to bring It Forward they're not
trying to hide it right they're not
doing it fraudulently they're going to
say okay it's within the look back
period so we have to honor the
guidelines of the program and that's the
proper thing to do and then you have to
use that money before Medicaid kicks in
that's the way it works so this is why
you get long-term care insurance and why
you build wealth so but uh Courtney I I
always resist situations where the
timing of the whole thing from a family
perspective is good for everyone but you
and this has got you right on the bubble
and so if it works out to where uh your
grandmother's a couple more years and
you've got time to pay off your student
loan have an emergency fund and have a
down payment and the payment on a
15-year fix is no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay and you like this
house
then go ahead but um I I and I won't
argue with you I'll take your word on
the fact that I was wrong about you
being forced into this thing but
um it's it's
if it was a six hundred thousand dollar
house you'd be out
it's not an option for you
even if you liked it I mean you could
qualify for it on 30-year but I would
tell you don't do it you can't afford it
so that that's where this is I mean you
they're everything in this story is on
the edge it's all on the bubble bubble
bubble bubble bubble usually we find
Courtney too just in general when you're
making big purchases like a house I mean
usually the largest purchase that you're
gonna make in your lifetime
is when things feel rushed or there's
not a lot of options sometimes you can
make a bad decision one of the most
peaceful ways to go about you know a big
purchase like a home is that there's
lots of options you have the right to be
out if you don't want it it just gives
you a lot of freedom and a lot of power
Courtney and I think what that what
you're saying Dave is when you start to
get pushed in this corner of like this
is the only thing that I can do
sometimes you don't always make the best
decisions so just give yourself the
permission to be released from it do the
numbers figure out this figure it out
and if it works for you then that's
great but just don't be forced into
something don't buy this house
with a student loan still on the books
pay that loan off today and then this
works for it doesn't this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author co-host of the
smart money happy hour and my daughter
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Dylan is with us in Miami hi Dylan
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks for having me
um I am 22 years old and I just
graduated undergrad and got married the
next day my wife and I don't have any
debt but
um two weeks after our wedding my mother
passed away oh no but um gosh I'm sorry
Dylan yeah
was that unexpected so
uh yes and no uh yes and the fact that
she declined so quickly
um she died at 61 so she left us
um her Ira which has about 300 000 in it
and then the main reason I'm calling is
because
the house that she left has sixty
thousand dollars left on it and I'm just
wondering should I what I'm planning to
do is rent it out and have my renters
pay the mortgage but I also have the
life insurance which is I got about 90
000 left on that just kind of sitting in
my bank account should I just go ahead
and pay the mortgage off completely and
then have that passive income or or what
would you guys do wow I'm so sorry
that's completely
tough two weeks after you're married to
make all these decisions
I wish we could I wish we could slow
down okay you here's the thoughts that
pop into my head okay number one uh
renting a property as a landlord is not
passive income
that's humorous
that's crap from Tick Tock okay uh
because there's nothing passive about
dealing with renters I've got a bunch of
them uh I have been I am planning to
hire a property it doesn't matter it's
not passive this is very active you you
have a hassle factor in your life called
renter okay it's just part of they'll be
renting your mom's home and they're
going to be in the home you probably
grew up in right
right yeah yeah that's weird emotionally
it's hard okay so that that's number one
thing so
um
can this be done yes it can be done
uh you're 22 you're brand new married
in my opinion the last thing you need is
the hassle of a rental property
um but if you're going to keep this and
give that a try
uh you should pay it off
um okay okay and uh because that will
lower the hassle you won't have a
payment anyway and so take the insurance
money out of the checking account pay
the mortgage off I normally wouldn't
like to make that decision on that
property that quickly but I will tell
you like the current the rate the home
Rachel grew up in is now in my rental
portfolio we kept it
it is weird I haven't lived in that
house in 20 years
it is weird to go over to that house
with other people's crap in it still
emotionally
and I'm I landlord a bunch of property
and I grew up in the real estate
business so I've got a huge advantage
over you and I'm old I've done this a
lot okay you're 22 this is your first
property I'm warning you that the first
time that they
screw around with the house you grew up
in they being the tenant uh it's going
to be emotional for you just be ready
for that okay no one it's never going to
be the same
it's never going to smell the same in
there
okay uh and so all of that now so if you
want to get a professional property
manager that's great are you local Dylan
where the house is yeah are you guys
close
I'm not I'm about I'm in Miami the
houses in Central Florida that's not too
bad I I don't like long-distance
landlording either so
I I'm gonna tell you that it with all
the emotions if we had a little bit of
time to digest all of this
I might just sell it but that's even a
harsher thing than letting a runner be
in it so I it's not an automatic thing
that a 22 years old two weeks after
you're married you ought to be a
landlord
that's not an automatic thing
okay so it's an automatic thing you
probably shouldn't do actually uh just
in terms of quality of life for you but
it's thrown in your lap and here we are
so if you want to try it just be
forewarned that this is not it's not
passive uh you're going to have some
emotions around other people and smells
being in your house no pets
I love pets one of my favorite things on
the planet is my little dog but no pets
not in my rental properties okay we call
them ten thousand dollar cats they
devalue your house ten thousand dollars
when they put the cat in there okay yeah
and so sorry that's the way that works
so this
experience
Dylan for you and your wife where are
you guys at financially I know you said
you have no debts
um you obviously have this 300
000 Ira from your mom uh are you do you
and your wife do you all rents do you
own a home where are you guys at
yeah we're renting we're we're just kind
of getting started financially our
combined income is probably around 70 or
80.
okay I would sell this house and buy you
a house I know how much is that how much
would the house how much is the house
worth do you know
right now it's probably worth 250 maybe
300 tops I would sell this house and buy
you a house and when I say that out loud
two weeks after you got married your mom
dies that's very harsh for me to say
that yeah it's hard for you to even hear
that and think about that but five years
from today you having this as a rental
property versus you and your new wife
having a new home to live in
that's a much better wiser decision
and yeah
um I you know I know I'm asking a lot
for you to process of a lot of emotions
and you don't have to make this decision
today Dylan and you don't have to do it
because I should do it but yeah you know
give yourself some time and kind of just
you know maybe you try the renting thing
for a year and I would still pay it off
and maybe you look up in a year and you
and your wife like man we want to get
settled somewhere you have a great asset
that your mom left you which is such a
gift and you can use that gift to
continue her Legacy I mean that what a
beautiful thing that she you know has
for you guys so
um maybe it's not right now but maybe
you look up in six months and think okay
we can make we can make this decision
but for you and your family now going
forward you and your wife
um you can really use this to jump start
you guys if the shouse had no emotion
tied to it if it was if she had it as a
rental property right you would have
sold it already in your mind you would
you wouldn't I'm gonna buy me and my
brother new house you wouldn't be going
I'm gonna rent and yeah and let me say
this this may not be Dylan's case real
quick but the idea of how having real
estate it's a big deal it's a big deal
people want a rental property you don't
have a rental property two hours away
and be renting yourself yeah no I agree
but I'm just saying I know Dylan I mean
I if I can get into a 22 year old's head
what the the kind of content that's out
there and what people are saying about
about for sure personal finance I'll
tell you you got to have a rental house
yeah but it's a very appealing thing
right to have this quote unquote active
income not passive but yeah so so
there's a I I get where you're at Dylan
but I think what you have to realize is
when you set you and your wife up really
well
then in 10 years you could get into this
if you want the rentals you want yeah
yeah and you'll be a millionaire yeah
and you'll have a paid for home for you
and your new bride the impact on your
marriage is positive the impact on your
health is positive uh the impact on your
finances is positive I just man I'm
sorry I'm sorry you're having to make
these decisions but that's what I would
do if I woke up in your shoes sir this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
Cruise Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from neighborly your hub
for Home Services is your to-do list too
long whether it's a simple repair or a
whole list of Home Improvements Mr
handyman's experienced professionals are
here to help you make your home work for
you visit neighborly.com Ramsay and you
can find expert Home Services this is a
really good company you guys it includes
locally operated Mr Handyman near you
today's question comes from Katie in
Utah for several months now I keep
hearing ads for title theft Insurance
the ads and warnings keep getting louder
I truly feel that someone is not going
to seal the title to your home but
there's lots of media people promoting
it that our title is in a trust and
there is no mortgage on the house or
property can you shed some light on the
subject sure sure Title Insurance
completely bogus
do not buy it
absolute crap
okay how do you really feel I just
wouldn't want to beat around the bush or
anything I want to make sure I'm clear
so uh so basically title fraud insurance
would say someone
signed your name to sell your house and
recorded that at the courthouse
okay that transaction would be undone in
about 30 seconds with a lawyer going
before a judge and said person that
signed that would be in jail for
criminal fraud
Grand Theft Auto hello it's a you know
they just stole a 200 000 asset or
attempted to without how could they even
do that they're fraudulent transaction
well I mean they don't pull the title
and just if you prepare a deed yeah
and you can type one up right and you
sign these owner's name to the deed
selling it
okay and you have that notarized and you
took that to the courthouse and recorded
it that's how I TR that's how I say hold
on property happens if I'm selling a
property I signed the deed and they
record it at the courthouse and the
buyers transfers it into the buyer's
name that could be done fraudulently the
number of times that happens is very
close to zero
it never happens because it's so absurd
okay because the person that did it
would instantaneously be caught
hello and go to jail I mean there's
nowhere they crook can hide it's not
like internet fraud where they can hide
in Russia or something right that they
have to actually you know they they
whoever wherever that money went you
know I mean and the buyer would of the
property would have been defrauded as
well and they're going to get nothing
and you couldn't get title insurance on
it you couldn't get you know there's no
way you could get anything so title
theft now I do have you know I do
recommend Identity Theft Protection in
general because there's a lot of kinds
of identity theft out there and that's
why we've had Xander Insurance doing
that for years we've recommended ID
theft from Xander I've got it on me I've
got it on all the kids the grandkids
everybody's got it all the employees
here have it furnished as a benefit uh
Alexander's identity theft but it's not
title theft and so
um
washed up actors will promote anything
on a commercial if you pay them okay so
media figures quote unquote a lot of
financial products a lot of gold a lot
of whole life I mean there's a lot of
reverse mortgages reverse mortgages I
mean you got The Fawns over there doing
that you know and Henry Winkler and you
got uh Magnum PI doing that I mean you
know but I mean it's not like they know
anything about reverse mortgages they're
actors for God's sake so they used to be
actors before they retired hello so I
mean it's like golly so no I mean that
these are not legitimate that does not
legitimize the product no crap don't do
not buy title theft Insurance now make a
distinction
there is a title policy that you buy
when you buy a home where you get title
insurance but it's not theft it's title
insurance that the insurance that the
title is clean Always by that that's
been a standard part of a real estate
transaction for 50 years okay and never
buy a piece of property without Title
Insurance ensuring that the title is
clean it's not that expensive and I have
had in all the I mean I've owned what
two almost three thousand pieces of real
estate in my life and I've had a handful
of instances where the title wasn't
clean and the title insurance company
that guaranteed the title to be clean
had to come back in and pay the other
one off oh well yeah I bought I bought a
little house I was flipping in the uh
a million years ago and uh uh these two
sisters sold it to me out of an estate
and they forgot they had a brother
so uh and he was not really they took
the money and they didn't they didn't so
we didn't have the brother's signature
and they were the three heirs to the
estate and the title company that did
the title search missed that and did not
certain you know and so the Two Sisters
sign up and then they had the brother
shows up going his one-third of my house
sure and uh so the title insurance
company you know they had to pay old
brother off speaking of like trends that
we're seeing so this title theft
Insurance she's seeing on social media
you're seeing all these like Financial
products here's one on social media and
I I probably I
I'm gonna just ask you on the air
because I think I can't wrap my head
around I'm trying I went down the rabbit
a whole one time and I'm like I can't
quite figure it out here here's a here's
a trend that's out there and I'm seeing
it maybe because the algorithm just
keeps speaking to me a lot of financial
people talking about using life
insurance while you're alive
talk about that explain that because I
get people sending me these these reels
and they're like we all please talk
about this because it's a trend right
now a lot of people that are like this
is what rich people do this is what
they're claiming in the videos well
there's
two different things the rich people
thing is the well that's the infinite
banking well they just roll they just
put those always in the videos okay but
that's that's the answer and they're
always selling their products that's bad
whole life but the viatical is uh a
person okay I've got a million dollar
life insurance policy on me and I've
been diagnosed with terminal cancer no
this isn't what they're talking about
there's no sickness involved oh this is
the just the infinite banking okay so
Kiku yeah do that one okay
infinite banking is a another word for
whole life life insurance that's all
it's whole life yeah that's all it is
it's just whole life oh you put a bunch
of money in it and then you borrow your
own money out yeah infinitely yeah which
you've always been able to borrow your
own money that's not new it's your money
you don't have to borrow it but you're
doing it through a life insurance you
put a chunk of money way too much into
are you over fund okay okay so what so
you put 50 000 like up front in a whole
life policy you prepay it yeah and so it
creates instantaneous cash value so it's
in there yes and so I got a cash value
now if I want my cash value out of my
whole life there's only two ways to get
it it's my money that's in there right
right the only two ways to get it cancel
the policy take my money back out sure
they're gonna kill you with fees yeah or
I can borrow my own money and pay them
interest
to borrow my own money and you can do
that infinitely so it's called infinite
banking it's infinitely stupid okay
well I'm glad I asked yeah
we had a guy call in to defend it the
other day and he and I got to argue on
there it was kind of fun yeah so well
that's a that's a big thing because
they're like you can go and like you can
live this great life that's a ticket and
you don't have to like that's an
absolute bull crap yeah okay the only
way you have a million dollars in a life
insurance policy is if you put a million
and a half in there
that's the only way it's in there I mean
and it makes one and a half to two
percent and when you die you lose your
money it's whole life life insurance
it's the worst Financial product in the
middle class it's the payday lender of
the middle class it sucks beyond belief
because here's the classic so here's
here's like element here's like
kindergarten Rachel Finance so instead
take your million dollars and put it in
an account
and live off the interest where you're
not oh that was deep definitely you can
do it infinitely I know but I'm just
telling you you watch these videos and
I'm like what I what is this guy call
down there he's like Banks do this and
I'm like Banks do not do this they do
not do banks do not buy whole life life
insurance that's a dumb but statement
that you can only make up on Tic Tac I
mean that's absolutely ludicrous Banks
buy bonds that's where they Place their
liquidity is in bonds and that's it's
that's why your cost of money goes with
a bond market oh my God this these
people just make crap up but I you know
it's like nothing down real estate you
know I've seen it about three times in
30 years it comes around and everybody
wants to do it and whole life life
insurance comes back around because
somebody that's young and dumb decided
it was cool and decides to promote it
and they can make a lot of money selling
it sell their products
yeah the commissions on it are ungodly
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and
remember hallow is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hallow.com
Ramsay today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personalities my
co-host today Emma is in Pittsburgh hi
Emma welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
okay so my husband and I used to own a
bunch of rental properties
um and we ended up going bankrupts
because we listened we had your book and
somebody else's book and the other
person's book said it was okay to have
debt whenever you're renting
um we ended up being over a hundred
thousand dollars worth of credit card
debt you know just because you things
were breaking in all of the houses yeah
and you had no and you had no margin
because you put nothing down yeah right
and we have a family of six so there was
a lot of mouths to feed and I had some
health issues and I was homeschooling
those four kids so there was only one
income and y'all lost all that we we did
lose all of it yes um when was that Emma
that was
2017. yeah me too it was 1988 yeah okay
well we got out of that got to the point
where we could buy another house and
spot 16 500 worth of credit card debt
which
I'm trying to pay that down I've got a
spreadsheet where we're down
3538 dollars good in the last six months
okay
um but still the total debt is with a
five thousand dollar balance on a car is
223 480 that counts your house
yes how much is that your house I mean
that's all your house except for you got
the little credit card debt and the you
got twenty thousand dollars plus your
house right
yeah that's
that's about it yeah and what's your
household income
it's right now sitting at 95 . okay and
so what's your question
so my question is
I'm finding my emotional relationship
with money is bad you know the love of
money is the root of all kinds of evil
I hate money and I get it you are
avoiding evil
it's a spiritual stance on Emma's part
honestly my I have I have some family
issues where my one family member has a
lot of money and he is not a really nice
person he uses it to manipulate people
and yeah so I don't want to be like him
well money doesn't money didn't make him
that way money exposed the fact that he
is that way
all money does is all money does is
magnify
okay if you're a jerk and you get money
you're big jerk if you're crazy and you
get money Big Lots of crazy okay if
you're if you're kind and compassionate
and generous and you get money you're
what we'd be called a philanthropist
like you change whole worlds because you
give so much
so you know it's not money it's just you
just got a jerk in the family well
welcome to being in a family
okay so you but you've had so you have a
negative relationship with money is what
you're trying to say I'm not making fun
of that I'm just laughing with you
because you're funny I like you okay so
and so it's caused a lot of pain Emma is
what you're saying money is a place and
you don't feel like you have a good
handle on it because you guys have this
credit card debt and you just think oh
my gosh I just feel like I I have no
control over this part of my life it
doesn't feel yeah let's prove that by
going bankrupt once Yeah Yeah well yeah
and I did too and yeah yeah then you got
to decide am I going to happen to this
money subject or is it going to happen
to me
um and and what's what's going on is
it's been happening to you yeah and I
think understanding Emma it's not just
the money part I mean I think the money
exposes some things but I think I wrote
a book called know yourself know your
money and I'll give you a copy of that
yeah that's perfect for this but it's to
understand why do I handle money the way
I do and I think for you and I think
it's some good kind of questions to ask
yourself everything from how you were
raised uh what kind of you know tension
was money in the household what kind of
value did your parents place on it and
kind of walking through that
understanding your Tendencies you know
are you more of a spender or a saver are
you more scarcity mindset or abundance
um what what what's your biggest fear a
lot of people are driven by fear they
don't want to end up you know how they
grew up you know a lot of people have
that fear so they'll go they'll swing
the pendulum so far where they save so
much because they don't want to you know
be poor like they were growing up and
they saw the hardship or whatever it is
right so everyone has their own their
own stuff so that plus Emma being
married
you haven't you have a spouse that has
the all different factors of everything
we just listed and so working together
and all of that can create
yeah just a lot of a lot of attention a
lot of stuff that combined with the
failure on the other part yeah and with
a house full of kids at home school all
of those things combined to uh take away
your confidence
and your power your emotional power over
money does that sound does that sound
right
yeah that sounds yeah perfect are you
guys Emma um you and your husband do you
guys do a monthly budget
we look at money we look at the debt
together yeah and we're okay to get that
number down I'm gonna pile you on with
some stuff I'm gonna give you every
dollar a premium okay as well in this
call because I think one of the things I
can feel so out of control and people do
this a lot Ms I'm not picking on you but
they're like oh yeah I just have kind of
all the expenses in my head and it's
just it's like it's this imaginary thing
that can suddenly become very isolating
it can be very scary when you don't see
the facts and Dr John's only talks about
this all the time that facts are your
friends and I think a budget honestly
working in that and seeing okay here's
our income that's coming in because you
guys make a great income I mean 95 Grand
you're doing great but to be able to say
here's the plan for that and then for
you over the course of time and I bet
you if you guys start that this month I
bet by January February there's going to
be a level of confidence over this Emma
because because you're going to learn
how to live within boundaries and make
different decisions and you're gonna be
at the grocery store and be like okay we
got 2 200 bucks this week I can spend
that and I don't have to worry yeah and
what what do I have to what do I have to
spend to stay within that and it's this
practice of discipline and being in
control of what that's what the budget
does and I think that really will give
you guys a sense of a sense of
confidence too I think the 3 500 in debt
that you paid off is absolutely amazing
because you've been beating it with a
hammer not slicing it with a sharp knife
and Rachel just gave you a sharp knife
it's going to go a lot easier you just
beat the heck out of it yeah and you
just beat the snot out of it this 3500
was heavy lifting you gutted that out
girl because you didn't have it you
didn't have a sharp knife you're just
wailing on it with a club you guys
should also know that most of my
children are six foot tall and our food
budget is sixteen hundred dollars a
month
so that's okay that doesn't mean you
can't that doesn't mean you can't get
control of money okay that I I know
there's places I know there's other
places I can cut spending yeah so I
think that's what it is you don't even
know where your spending is because you
don't have it all written out right you
get every stinking detail you will be
amazed you and your husband sit down and
look at where every single dollar is
going before the month begins and give
every dollar an assignment that's why we
call the app every dollar so because
you're giving every dollar a mission
okay and when you do that you're both
going to go where the crap have we been
doing and try this you know sixteen
hundred dollars that's before a budget
try 1400 for the month right like you
start practicing this like ebb and flow
and see okay where can we get an extra
100 few hundred dollars here or there I
mean like it's amazing the the power
that that really does give you and to be
able to cut stuff but honestly I think
for you guys getting some quick wins
because I think it's I think you said in
my confidence that it took six months to
pay off thirty five hundred that so I
want you to do that even faster no
you're gonna do it a lot faster because
you're gonna have a sharp notches you're
gonna have that so I think that's gonna
start to give you guys confidence
um but I think it's just rewiring these
habits and it takes time because you're
not a failure Emma and that's the other
thing is that this people equate their
net worth or their money mistakes to who
they are and that's when they talk about
shame that shame is your identity so so
take those apart that you are not the
past mistakes that you've made you are
not your net worth that is not who you
are Emma and so there's a level there
that I want you to to release that
because that stuff will follow you and
those lies will just will play a play a
tape in your head that you don't need
yeah you're doing better than you think
you are especially considering how blunt
the instrument is you're using yeah but
stay online because Austin I want to
give her know yourself know your money
and every dollar premium you're gonna
love that book camera because it's
exactly talking about you it's the
number one bestseller and you don't want
to miss it it's know yourself know your
money by Rachel Cruz and uh it's all
that not only family history but your
tendency scarcity abundance all that
stuff it's brilliantly done you will
love it and we'll put you in the every
dollar budgeting app and that will
change everything you and your husband
do that together and turn off the stupid
TV until the six Footers to go in the
other room we're working on the budget
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personalities my
co-host today Ray is in El Paso Texas hi
Ray how are you
hi Dave Rachel thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
well um I was calling because I uh
recently moved to El Paso from Colorado
uh we sold the house in Colorado and
made a good profit off of it
um we are renting in El Paso because
we're not going to be there that long
and so
I'm trying to figure out what to do with
this profit that I've made for the next
at least five years probably hopefully
not much longer after that until we're
ready to use it for the next piece of
property or home that we they're going
to be there five years
uh we are probably only going to you
know pass about three I'm active duty uh
hours there but okay I'm nearing
retirement so we won't stay okay
93 of the five-year periods in the stock
market's history have made money
so if you put it in a good growth stock
mutual fund or just an S P 500 which is
a good growth stock mutual fund and
leave it alone five years 93 times out
of 100 you'll make some money and this
year you would have made 17 18 on your
money
right okay now okay here here this
of the three-year periods made money
one out of three times if you live alone
only three years would you make money
one out of three times you'd lose money
two out three times you'd make money
okay
okay now here's the trade-off uh how
much money are we talking about
uh hundred seventy thousand dollars okay
and so if you lost ten percent that'd be
highly unusual in either one of those
scenarios
losing money might be losing three
percent okay but if you lost ten percent
you lost seventeen thousand dollars it
does not wreck your world
right okay so I'm putting it in a growth
stock mutual fund something like an s p
you can sit down with a smartvester pro
if you're going to leave it alone at
least three years there is a some good
Investments already uh like and I saw
the same things you just said when I
looked at it but I think I'm just a
little bit gun shy because it's more
money than I've ever deal with before
well I mean what you need to be prepared
of is say could I could I could I deal
with it what's the absolute
statistically you know one percent of
the time if you had a horrible you you
were the absolute worst three-year
period that you could have possibly
picked and you lost twenty percent you
lost 30 grand
you're still okay you're okay right but
you're not going to lose 100 000 on this
okay I'm not I mean I really I don't
think you are I mean we got other
problems in the economy if you lose that
much
yeah this whole place has got issues
then so um so I oftentimes in my
situation I can absorb that risk and so
I'll take a chunk even if I'm not even
leaving alone three years and I'll still
throw it to an s p so I throw spare
change into an s p until I get enough in
there to buy a piece of real estate is
what I do but it might only sit in there
a year and a half but this year I would
have made 17 on it versus if I put it in
a high yield savings account I would
have made four percent yeah they're
doing great though for that no but I
mean really it's kind it's humorous that
they call it I yield
it's basically a CD it's a certificate
of depreciation yeah right thanks for
your service yes I appreciate that and
that's exciting about about getting some
money and seeing seeing where it goes
cool beans very good stuff
Jay is in Atlanta hi Jay how are you
hey Dave I'm doing well how are you
doing today better than I deserve what's
up
yeah
um the reason I called in today I
recently accepted a sales position with
a uh with a new company
and the details that they gave me during
the interview process for the number of
appointments that kept and then can
um close rate and everything like that
does not reflect the reality
and the numbers are greatly skewed
um the close rate for instance was 33
during the interview the reality is
about 12 percent and then appointments
kept is is they said majority were kept
and then what were you selling before 35
percent
um so I've sold Financial products in
the past yeah when have you ever seen a
33 close rate
I would have smelled a rat as soon as I
saw that
this is a different type of it's it's
outside sales and I know
yeah that's high so yes it is very high
and that does actually reflect some of
the some of the actual cells okay are
they incompetent or are they crooked
I to be honest I'm brand new there and I
don't know the the numbers for these
types of leads are at 12 is the um I
know but I'm saying with you or with
other people working there
uh no this is uh with other people
working there yeah like this is across
the board with this particular type of
lead so you've been able to check this
out and it's system-wide it's 12 percent
yes okay and so they're either
incompetent or they lied yeah yes both
are scary to work for
yeah then I actually turned down another
job
um to take this one I had multiple
offers on the table and this one seemed
like the better offer yeah but I mean I
don't know how to that's water under the
bridge now do you want to work there
anymore that's the question
uh
honestly probably not that's what it
sounds like to me but I don't think the
last few weeks yeah I mean I'm a lot
more scared of incompetent than I am
Crooks actually but I don't want to work
for either one there's very few Crooks
but there's a lot of enthusiastic
ignoramuses out there
yes sir
okay so what do you what would you
approach yeah what I don't think you can
go in and confront them and change them
how would you approach a uh another
company that you had a job offer from I
would just telling the truth just tell
them the truth okay these guys I know
they gave me a close rate and I got over
there and it was one third of it
and um so you know and and it was all it
was almost a tie with you guys anyway I
would have loved to have gone to the
prom with you but
um you know the other girl lied to me so
I don't know I mean if you came to us
and you told us that we would feel like
we were your second choice but we were
but it's okay God worked it I really
wanted you yeah I mean it's obvious you
went somewhere else good at what you do
if you have multiple offers so even if
one of those companies doesn't I'm sure
there's another one out there yeah you
know
I have another outstanding offer as well
yeah so I think you're fine I just I
don't think you're going to feel good
about this company
I wouldn't okay
I mean I've just talked to you for three
minutes I don't feel good about them but
maybe there's more information that I
don't have but that you have but
um if if I literally I mean I I had a
guy that worked here that decided that
we were lacking in Integrity on an issue
and he quit
thank you that's what you should do you
shouldn't work for people that you don't
think has Integrity I actually thought
we had Integrity he didn't he quit
that's okay I get that I don't want to
work for somebody I don't think has
integrity and so you know I you know I
don't even want people I don't want
people working here that think that
we're incompetent or that think well we
don't have integrity sure yeah you
should go somewhere else I mean you
should go somewhere because it's hard to
be enthusiastic about these people
because and 2J if you say in that I'm
like I would be probably looking over my
shoulder anything that they say yeah to
like cut the what they say in the thirds
because I'm like you obviously don't
know either what you're talking about or
you're lying to me so yeah that's not a
yeah 40 hour you're gonna be working
there full time I'm like that's too many
hours something for the people you don't
believe in I mean yeah please come to
business with this company that doesn't
tell the truth you know yeah yeah no I
don't that's really sorry jay though
that's that's horrible to go through
that man I'm sorry makes you mad but um
and you kind of feel mad at yourself a
little bit because you missed it you
know I would and I'm not saying I'm not
saying he should yeah but I mean that's
a normal human emotion yeah to kind of
like God what how dumb am I you know I
just believe everyone I know I would be
like okay I mean but you know I had a
guy working here that was lying to me
and I believed him and I'm like how dumb
am I because I believe the guy right but
he's pathological liar but you know I
believed him that's my it's my I'm dumb
you know and I feel you get that's a
normal thing yeah yeah oh wow there you
go sorry jay I'm sure she'll get you
another sales job yeah you're obviously
good at what you do you got lots of
offers you're into great Life's too
short man
that puts us out of the Ramsay show in
the books
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth new work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author co-host of the smart money happy
hour on Ramsey networks and my daughter
is my co-host today thank you for
joining us America the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Cheryl is in Medford Oregon hi
Cheryl welcome to the Ramsay show
for taking my call this is a first time
caller and I'm a little
um
I'm happy to be here well we're honored
to have you glad you're here Cheryl
big breath so um I have a question
um
I'm in my late 60s and I'm married
happily to my husband we have five adult
children I've been listening for about a
year
and um what's changed and my situation
is my mom passed away about five minutes
ago I'm sorry
and um thank you um it's been uh she was
sick for a while so you know it still
was hard but the situation is she left
we grew up on a piece of property there
and she's in there since about 1958
and we all grew up there and now this
property is in a trust and we're all
trying to figure out how to divide it
amongst us
and it's just been
um really volatile not that I haven't
contributed to it because I I'm you know
a woman but um I just want to do and
honor the Lord and just
you know honor my sister and my brother
but it's difficult because they've all
put a lot of money into the ranch
and my mother has it in the estate that
she wants it divided amongst us and
we've kind of been an outsider because
we branched in other places
and now we're here now and we're just
trying to figure out our role what are
the what is the trust asking people to
do and what is it they don't want to do
um the trust has asked that we divided
equally amongst ourselves how is that
fair if they put money into it and you
didn't
um
let's see how do I go about that
um they they invested it in areas that
benefited them in in kind of a an area
that they wanted to
um how did it benefit them they didn't
own it
did they make money off of that
yes one was in uh hemp
um trying to grow him for a couple years
and building a building that utilized
that resource and then another was yeah
but that building now has a value
regardless of whether hemp's in it or
not
correct fifty thousand yeah and that
building if they built that building
with their money your mom didn't that
should be their money right
correct if I was them that's how I would
see it
okay
which is let me tell you the whole idea
that they would build a building on
someone else's property without having
everything lined out in the Trust In
detail was pretty stupid
because it sets up a big argument
your mother and your brothers and
sisters should have their butts kicked
for not doing this properly because it
leaves you in a lurch
so they what is it they're wanting to do
the brothers and sisters my sister has
a pretty uh
uh some of them legitimate and some of
them not and then she wanted
um 150 000 for providing care for my
mother
but the trust doesn't allocate that
no and then her she lived on the
property and her children did 50 of her
children did at the same time for the
last five years with no rent
correct okay
all right and so
um
well uh so I guess the negotiating is
that
um I assume you guys have an estate is
there who's the trustee
my brother oh Jesus
okay the youngest and so he's really
caught in this bless his heart yeah he
is yeah okay so his job
unless you guys come to a mutual
conclusion otherwise he doesn't have a
choice
he legally has to follow the terms of
the trust
whether he wants to or not
he is only out is that everyone agree to
something different and go along with it
but otherwise he's going to divvy this
up straight up he has to
because otherwise he's liable for suit
he is a fiduciary trust responsibility
as the trustee to execute the terms of
the trust if he doesn't any one of you
that are the beneficiaries would have
have cause against him so Cheryl the
fact that you know that there's other
you know they've put money into it how
are you feeling are you are you on one
side saying yeah you got to divide it up
a third a third a third it's what it
says or are you like I want to be fair
in this and do the right thing I just
don't know what it is where are you at
in all of it
well it's kind of complicated because
um
bald assets are on one part of the
property it's it's worth 2.2
but it's hard uh some of it's exclusive
farming and so you can't really do
anything with it and that necessarily
can build on it and that's the part that
we've been interested in but then when
we research it it's going to be pretty
expensive to try to you know put things
that we have to do to live there and we
live about an hour away why don't you
just sell it
and that's that's a possibility too and
just show your part oh
we just wanted to farm you know it's
kind of our way to to try to well we
have cattle we don't have a place for
them we've had we have a couple at the
ranch right now but
we have um so you're thinking about
moving on the property
well we've been thinking about it but
it's been next door to all these people
that you disagree with well that sounds
joyful that's what I'm concerned about
yeah I guess so
that doesn't sound fun at all
like next door to my brother who's still
mad about something that happened 15
years ago oh my God uh
uh I would have to have real good solid
loving harmonious relationships before
I'd want to live next door to them and I
don't know if this story you're telling
me ends there
so you need to consider that part of it
but here's the here's the here's your
bottom line on the whole thing
let's pretend that you wanted to allow
your
hemp brother and your sister tenant
to get a little more than you got
because they put buildings on it in my
mind uh the care that she provided for
your mom is offset by the fact she got
free rent so that's absolute bull I'm
dropping that one if I'm you but
um she gets nothing uh she already got
it it's called free rent and so then
whoever brought buildings on will take
the value of those buildings out of the
equation
and then split what's left three ways
then they get their buildings back and
so that because you should not benefit I
don't think ethically from them putting
a building on the property because you
didn't put money in it it's their money
again the whole thing was dum dum dum
dum dum
that you all that that the family did
this doing this stuff is how people end
up not speaking to each other
generationally you end up with the
Hatfields and The McCoys
and so
you know you're just you know it's just
dumb but anyway so that's water on the
bridge but let's say that you said all
right we're gonna take the buildings off
now we run an appraisal then you get
your buildings back
on so you you know you got you got your
buildings back and then I get my third
of what's left I would agree to doing
that and no 150 000 that is exchange for
the free rent if you all agree to that
then little brother the trustee can go
along with that otherwise he has to
execute the trust he does not have a
choice this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us America we're so
glad you're with us we appreciate you
being here I'm Dave Ramsey your host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right guys
um last call about the estate that's
messed up in the late 60s brothers and
sisters they're left fighting because
their parents and them did business very
poorly what is the takeaway a number one
takeaway
if you're 18 years old or older you need
a will
period
now let's understand what a will is
if I if I have a will if I uh will it
for if it is my will for Rachel to be on
the show she's on the show okay as a
guest or as a host co-host right okay if
I have a if if it is my will to wear a
green jacket today I will get it out of
the closet that's that's what you want
to have happen is your will
okay that's what I'm having a will means
this is what you will it's what you want
to have happen
in your last will and testament it's the
last thing you want to have happen and
you are testifying to that fact
that's all that means so this is what I
want to have happen when I do a will
and the executor of the will the word
executor is one who executes
they execute what I wanted to have
happen they don't have a choice same is
true of a trustee on a trust
the executor can't change the will
it's not their job
and even if they don't like it even if
they think it's not fair they can't just
change it the trustee can't change the
terms of the trust it's not their job
their job is to execute those the the
what that person intended to have happen
what they wanted what they willed to
have happen and they testified to that
fact okay so keeping your will up to
date is huge
it should be done in the state according
to the laws of the state in which you
reside so if you change States get a new
will
any other major thing that happens
divorce get a new will
death of a
someone that's in the will get a new
will
update your freaking will
because it's incomplete it's wrong you
can't execute it if you live in Idaho
and you did a will in Tennessee
okay it doesn't it's not federal law
it's state law
probate law is state law so yeah it's
done according to the laws of the state
you reside in when you die
and so if your will is done something or
asked for something to be done that the
laws of that state you're residing in
don't allow and you haven't updated it
you're screwed up the whole thing
this is called grown-up paperwork
grown-ups do a will
I might die you're gonna die
it does not increase your probability of
death when you do a will you're going to
die is a hundred percent death rate in
the human race okay plus or minus Elijah
and Jesus okay the rest of us are gonna
die okay so that's it you're gonna get a
will go to mama bear legal forms if you
have a basic uh life and you don't have
a lot of complication and get an
inexpensive will online it's a great
will but it's state specific Mama Bear
legal forms we've endorsed them for
years you've got a complicated situation
get an attorney get an estate planning
attorney
I have spent an amazing amount of money
on state planning to keep the
government's freaking hands off of it
and then once a year we have a little
meeting with all the Ramses and all the
leaders at Ramsey and we tell everybody
and it's labeled if Dave dies this year
that's the name of the meeting if Dave
dies this year it's we call it the Monty
Python meeting I'm feeling much better
it's just a flesh wound but yeah uh oh
my God and we sit and talk about my
death for an hour and a half
what has changed since last year in the
operation of Ramsey and the operation of
this piece of real estate going scuba
diving what are all the ways I do all
the stuff I do all the stuff so I'm not
gonna quit doing all the stuff that's
not the point because I'm gonna die in
this part of the program
so I'm I'm good with that because
Heaven's on the other side of it I'm
perfectly good with that so anyway get a
freaking will and when you're gonna do
stuff with a family piece of ground like
that family had and you're gonna I'm
gonna move in with my mind I'm Gonna
Take Care of Mama oh by the way I'm
charging all y'all 150k well kiss my
butt I don't think so
we can stop that on the front end we
don't have to have an issue here you're
going to move in take care of Mom so are
you expecting to be paid uh we're gonna
write all this down
uh or what do you think you should be
paid because I'm happy you're there to
take care of Mom okay I'm more than
happy with that and so if you get more
of the estate because you took I'm happy
with that but we should do all of this
in writing as a part of the program and
then not leave it behind confused and so
if you're doing something in your will
like I'm not going to leave Jim Bob any
money because Jim Bob does heroin and
he'll go get heroin and kill himself so
Jim Bob you're out of the will go ahead
and tell Jim Bob while you're alive
because he's going to be pissed and you
might as well have the pleasure of him
being pissed while you're alive
Stir It Up Stir It Up maybe it'll clean
him up but I mean go ahead you know this
this stuff of we're going to go into the
paneled Office of the lawyer and the
weird uh plastic surgery induced
stepmother and the inbred child and all
this other stuff in there like some
movie or and we're going to have a
reading of the will that only happens in
a movie
okay a bad movie and we've all seen the
movie all right several of them so in
real life real people go ahead and
communicate with their family they say
brother is putting a fifty thousand
dollar hemp building on the property God
help us and so brother is going to get
not gonna that fifty thousand dollar
building is not going to be included in
the value that is split three ways
because it's his freaking money and
we're going to write that into the trust
before brother because he apparently
smoking the hemp put the building on
there without freaking dictating that he
was going to get his own money back okay
so people listening though right now God
need to get a will yes but what do you
say to people because I get this
question a lot that my parents they
don't want to talk about it they don't
want to do a will whenever we try to
bring up the conversation they shut it
down well then don't put a building on
their property okay I know but but
what's your advice and what would you
say to someone though that's like how do
I help my parents see that they need a
will so that we're not in this situation
Mom and Dad we love you so much we would
love to see that your legacy has carried
out the way you want it to be carried
out when it's all in your head nobody
knows what the flip you want to have
happen so maybe you ought to write it
down it's called a will
it's what grown-ups do okay and by the
way by the way the government's going to
end up with a bunch of this too if you
don't if you're going to screw around
and do this right some of these Estates
that's a two million dollar estate there
that one is not going to be subject to
federal estate tax now but it would have
been under Obama
okay and so uh Trump's estate
limits are still in place right now
because Biden hadn't gotten around to
screwing that up but uh but he will
eventually
once he wakes up from well anyway the um
all right so I mean seriously people
write it down and then have a review
with your family here's what we want to
have happen I'll give you another
example okay the this is public
knowledge so I'm not telling some big
Tale the Ramsay kids now own the vast
majority of this company I own a
minority position but I own the only
voting stock so I'm still in control
okay we transferred that out of our
names Sharon will get none of this
company if I die before Sharon does
it'll go straight to the kids as part of
our estate plan
by the way Sharon knows that Sharon
doesn't want anything to do with this
place the kids are going to run it
that's what she does she just wants
money that's all she wants and so we got
that we got Miss Sharon set up because
we the whole estate plan is also
presupposing I'm going to die first
which means she has a plan so golly so
anyway that's an example though okay
that's a weird thing it didn't go to my
wife and then to my kids it went
straight to my kids
and uh and she's one of the owners prior
to that yeah two so but you talk about
this crap and you put it down in writing
it's called a will it's called a trust
that's updated so people do your Will
and tell everybody
about it that is in it or not in it so
that they don't have to fight about it
later this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I'm Dave Ramsey your host Rachel Cruz is
my co-host today Dennis is in Richmond
Virginia hi Dennis how are you
Hi how are you uh so my name is Dennis
I'm 20 years old and my question is uh
is it crazy that I'm asking my mom for a
loan of eight thousand dollars now I
know the question sounds crazy because
there's not really a backstory so can I
give you a brief backstory to go with it
sure
okay so I've been investing for about
two years now I'm I started my freshman
year at college and I've been day
trading for about a year and a half
um my closest one of my closest friends
is a up-and-coming headphone manager so
I get a little bit of information from
him but I mainly an investor
um about uh a year ago a year and a half
ago before I started really day trading
um I was only a referee that's my only
job I have because I'm in college so I
might make 500 in a weekend and I would
take uh probably about 300 out of that
500 and put it into Weeble to invest and
then just keep the other 200 to live off
and uh I'll just keep doing that and at
one point I asked my mom for three
thousand dollars because my um my father
had just paid all of our child all of my
child support at one time myself my year
um it was forty thousand dollars and I
was still trying to um you know remember
where's the money why do you need money
if you're day trading
why do I need money yeah did you lose
all your money
yes okay so you suck at day trading and
you want her to give you money
not really because yeah really you lost
all your money you suck at it
well it was 5
fuzzle made all the money I didn't lose
where's the money how much money do you
have 30 000 how much money do you have
right now I own I don't have any money
in my brokerage account because I took I
took the rest of it out because I didn't
want to go any lower for how much money
have you lost day trading
uh I lost about 15
000 in the a week yeah that's what made
me take my money out yeah but I've also
gained about 27
000 in less than a year yeah so okay let
me give you the numbers on this okay
of day Traders
lose money net net
when the story is over eight out of ten
day Traders lose money
20 year old day traders who referee it's
the numbers approaching a hundred
percent
don't do this anymore
and your mother's right no she should
not give you money I would not give you
money
because you're going to lose it
even if you can see that the games are
there and if you check the company I
just told you 8 out of ten day Traders
lose money you're 20 freaking years old
and you referee games on the weekend
what makes you think you're better than
the others people
okay you're gonna lose money then
yes I understand that then why would you
keep doing this
it gives me more money to invest at a
certain point my mom told me like her
mindset she's nobody in the family
invested or does any of this stuff
because they don't want to do it like
you told me that I was stupid she's
right no I was I was first investing
this is when she told me that I was dumb
for investment or taking half my
paycheck and just investment stuff I I
recently just found out day trading and
at first I didn't day trade I would just
heads so that's where it had brought me
up the amount of money I bought some as
doll calls and bought semester yes you
are playing a game that guys that get
paid millions of dollars a year play and
most of them aren't good at it
I mean guys that run multi-billion
dollar mutual funds do what you do and
they still have questionable results
it takes them years and years and years
of training and experience to do this
not I've got a friend who was once
worked for a hedge fund and I'm 20 and I
Referee on the weekends you are you are
the recipe of a disaster sir please
don't do this anymore your mom is right
she smells a rat and it's you're gonna
hurt yourself son stop it I don't think
I'm gonna talk you out of it because I
think you're convinced yourself but dude
I mean
listen if eight out of 10 people that
walk down the street named a street get
attacked by a bear and killed
don't walk down a street
I mean this is it this is not I mean
why do I think what am I going to get a
bear suit I mean no I mean don't walk
down a street eight out of ten people
that walk down the street a bear kills
them son that's what I'm telling you you
know and Dennis I think please don't act
like you're different yeah and I think
the appeal right when you get rich quick
it is that's what I'm saying because I'm
like there's such a better formula to
handle your money long term
um and I think you have the you know you
have the capacity to do that to do it
the right way Dennis that lowers the
risk it's not going to be as exciting
and it's not going to be like boom boom
Oh my gosh this this and that it's not
going to bring that but it's going to
bring a level of stability and build a
really great financial life for yourself
by starting great habits I'm like just
slow down if you have debt Dennis pay it
off have some cash in the bank to save
and you're you you hustle you you're
looking for opportunity it's just your
momentum and your focus is just geared
in a way that's really risky and you're
not going to come out better on the
other end I'm playing this versus doing
in the Commodities Market is almost as
dumb if not Dumber I did that
I have a finance degree I actually know
something about this stuff formally
academically studied it hello
um it was not I had a friend that was in
a hedge fund and a guy comes to me and
goes hey my buddy over here has been
doing gold trades and we're going to buy
some Futures on the gold trades at the
last 11 times that he has picked the
future date in our our purchase rate on
the thing and if we put in 5 000 bucks
we'll get 50 000 out the last he's 11
for 11 on his last five guess what I put
in 5 000 bucks in the 12th one he missed
which means you lose the whole five
thousand bucks you either get 50 or you
get nothing that's how this works so I
saw that was my gold investment because
I'm just as stupid and dumb I mean just
as everybody else I had to try it
because I'm smarter than everybody else
let me tell you Pride goes right before
the fall
once you think you find somebody's got
it all figured out and they got a system
yeah bullcrap okay the only system that
works is long-term investing in
long-term track record things where 80
90 of the people doing it make money not
where 80 90 of the people lose money and
you think you're the freaking exception
this is how Vegas is operated everybody
thinks they're the exception and that's
why Bellagio has nicer Furniture in
their Lobby than you do because you paid
for it you people that thought you were
smarter than the house
that's why they have chilooy or whatever
that uh architecture it is crazy what is
the name of that famous sculpture that
does the lighting oh I know chili or
whatever Lighting in the lobby the blown
glass yeah probably probably chewy is
that it truly are you terrible the guys
in the booth are trying to help me with
my hillbilly but uh yeah it's like a
million dollar picture in the lobby
right that's fantastic right over the
right over there right over where you
check in and guess who paid for that
stupid people that's who paid for that
okay people that thought they were going
to beat the house listen if you do it
for entertainment and you're out of debt
stupid people small amount of money and
you choose it's not entertaining to lose
money it's not entertaining to think
you're the exception of the rule I know
feel that way
help us you and Dennis go invest
together that's what you all need to do
no it's just the long-term play Dennis
don't don't please hey great for
refereeing yeah good for you no I'm just
saying that doesn't qualify you to be a
day trader I know because you can call
up five-year-old soccer game this
doesn't set you up to be a day trader
it's not it's not like the prerequisite
to winning it day trading
so um you know he does do hard work
thank you for that yes and thank you for
earning some extra money and so forth
but I think your mom is a precious lady
I love her she's got some sense mom
don't give Dennis any money
there you go
uh not for day trading that's right
sorry Dennis you didn't get what you
wanted here but you will always get the
truth because we love you and we don't
want to lie to you we want you to have a
good life and so we're always going to
tell you the truth even if it's fun this
is the Ramsay show
oh
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the day Deuteronomy 28
12 the Lord will open to you his good
treasure the Heavens to give the Reign
to your land in its season and to bless
all the work of your hand you shall lend
to many nations but you shall not borrow
that's the blessings
on the house of Israel on the people of
Israel the promise when they go into the
Promised Land
the curse is ibarro the blessing is you
are having rain on your land in its
season Jim Henson said the only way the
magic works is by hard work
but hard work can be fun
father father of the Muppets yes I
didn't know that all right Stephanie is
up Stephanie is in Minneapolis hi
Stephanie how are you
sure what's up uh so a little bit of
context my husband and I are three years
into marriage we did a ramsay-ish thing
for the past two years but we have
gotten really gazelle intent on baby
step two
um and we are looking to be out of debt
within the next eight or so months
congratulations thanks so after doing
this of course Murphy comes around and
what we're facing right now is that my
husband's mom uh is looking at about
fifty thousand dollars in dental work
that needs to be done all of her teeth
have to be extracted she needs Dentures
or implants or something like that and
she is looking to us for help so uh she
called and asked my husband to fill out
a loan application while she was at the
dentist and he was like but I can't do
this right now I'll call you back later
so of course we talked and learned more
that she's hoping that maybe we would if
we aren't willing to do that we take out
a home equity line of credit or maybe
settle the house so as a little bit of
background my husband purchased this
home for his mom a few years back before
we got married but by purchase I mean
she paid the down payment
um and she has been giving him money to
pay the mortgage but he had the credit
score he had just graduated from college
and so they used his credit score his
name for first-time homebuyer and this
debt has been weighing on him because if
anything happens to her at any moment
then we are now responsible for that
house as well
you live in that house
we do not live in that house okay where
is that house
that house is in Connecticut oh that's
her house
yes okay so she's going to sell her
house
no it's technically in his name so oh
sorry he could sell he could sell the
house that she lives in
and get get rid of the debt and she
would have the money for her dental out
of the house that is hers
it's morally hers but it's in his name
right so then we don't understand fully
the tax implications
of selling the house and then giving her
that money
uh how much money is it
uh the dental work would be no no how
much is the house worth oh the house is
worth about 350 360
000. okay what did they pay for it
000. I'm at 360 and 235 was that the two
numbers
yes and how long have they had it
uh probably about six years now okay
all right and he's not been depreciating
it as a rental property on his taxes has
he
nope okay good
and
um
okay there may be a little bit of tax
involved
but it won't be a ton okay it'll be 15
of the gain the gain would be 360 minus
the selling expenses which will probably
be thirty thousand so about 330. so you
might have a hundred thousand dollars in
gain and it might be fifteen thousand
dollars in taxes so I would sell the
house
and pay the taxes and give her the money
okay and is there a gift tax on yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna have to manipulate this
because this was a dumb bad deal
and it's going to take a little bit of
work to get out of it but no we're not
borrowing money if she wants to sell her
house by the way she needs to get a
second and third opinion
uh I've been doing Financial coaching a
long time I have never yet heard of a
fifty thousand dollar Dental operation
not once unless there was some kind of
car accident
well if they're taking all of her teeth
out I don't put in veneers or something
I don't care I I really want to get a
second and maybe a third opinion
okay on this yeah in other words if
you're going to do a fifty thousand
dollar uh remodel you'll get three bids
the same thing here okay because I'm I'm
I'm
suspect
okay so yeah I think if Mom wants to
sell the house that's hers we got to
figure out what the tax implications are
and that money has to be held back and
the rest of the money she can have and
use for her dental
okay but no I'm not gonna borrow money
no and she doesn't she and don't put a
HELOC on the house obviously no it's not
in your name you already got enough debt
in your name yeah exactly yeah so she's
now a renter with good teeth
[Music]
oh man I'm sorry what a mess let me tell
you though this is a really clean break
to something that's going to get worse
year by year
this is going to go sideways at some
point because this lady doesn't handle
money well
and he's propped her up with his
purchase and it's going to go sideways
someday so this is the this is a good
time for it to go sideways and get it
cleaned up and get all get his name off
of all of her debt the death that's
associated with her
so the best thing is to sell
let her take the money and just keep
whatever this house meaning the one she
lives in that's in your husband's name
right yeah but get to get tax you got
two types of taxes you have to consider
like you said gift tax is there a way to
work around that
and then you also have to consider the
capital gains tax on it capital gains
tax probably gonna be around 10 or 15
000 bucks on this based on what our what
you told me
something like that and then if you can
you can probably move around some stuff
on the gift tax and not have any but you
probably need to do it how much is gift
tax a couple of generations it's
ridiculous if you get into it but
um what is the thing this year I can't
even remember to get my cheat sheet out
it's fine uh 16 022. okay so it's
probably up a little bit from that so
it's probably twenty thousand so
you know that that she that much of it's
not going to be taxable but the rest of
it they're going to do something with
yeah
um and I don't know you're gonna you
need tax advice and you need a realtor
um but I think this whole story is going
to change when you tell Mom the house is
sold
because right now she's going to do is
borrow and now she's got to move
so I think this is going to change I bet
you the whole thing blows up but I'm
just but I'm trying to stir up trouble
because trouble needs to be stirred up
here because it's going to come sooner
or later yeah and we might as well go
ahead and get it out of the way because
um
yeah you don't have a money problem
Stephanie you got a mother-in-law
problem and I'm trying to help you with
that so get get her that's what's hard
about good clear boundaries yep and in
that situation like she said he
graduated college had a good credit
score mom needs a house I'll take it out
in my name right all the your husband
this have happened your husband didn't
tell his mother no when he should have
but he wouldn't know too though that's
what I'm saying is a lot of this stuff
though this is where it is it's it's the
good intention yeah it makes sense mom
can't get the house but I can put it in
my name she can pay me like it all
sounds good until you're married
[Laughter]
and also it's that's why you have to be
careful with money and the good
intention with family members and
friends so don't put your name on other
people's debt ever and if you're gonna
loan if you wanna if someone's asking
for a loan you either give it or say no
but this whole like attached your name
to my stuff and my money thing that it
just gets weird it gets weird so
remember it's clean everything needs to
be clean
I guess I'm gonna get a hate mail from
dentists but that's okay I'm trying to
get it trying to get more of them I
think Dental stuff is expensive though
yeah well yeah and sometimes and yeah
check it get a bid yes get another
opinion it's not a bad it so we're not
getting we're not doing drywall but
don't get a bit but yeah yeah
get several opinions and estimates and
is there other ways to
because this sounds like a complete
reconstruction
or something yes like oh man nasty
extracting everything and a whole new
set of teeth
young young young people you 18 year
olds 17 year olds 22 year olds parents
come to you asking to do stuff like this
don't
I love you Mom no
and by the way no Izzy I love you Dad no
freaking sentence there you go I love
you dad sometimes the dads yeah well
this was Mom I know I know come on come
on that puts this hour the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the Ramsay
show if you want to do your debt free
scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com debt free screen
we'd love for you to come to Nashville
and tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]